and today's hay is errors in measurement
twit T is it xx us today so we're
looking at areas in measurement that
remember when I said she by the
beginning his tell me your major stuff
you've got to deal with well
what units you measuring you but not
only do you have to think about units
but you have to think about the fact
that you're using most of the time
physical instruments to actually measure
these things out and they're never gonna
be like a hundred percent exact a
million different places exact precise
okay so errors are always going to creep
in in some way I know talking about
three kinds of errors just like before
we had like all these different
categories of
units so if you have like kind of three
dot points yeah the three kind of errors
go basically like this number one where
you start measuring phone so I call
these starters now there are two common
ways that you can do this I'm gonna draw
some pictures for you
if we go with save the rule on okay if
you have a close look at the rule which
I'm going to show you right now this now
this one's pretty interesting because
very close but if you guys have got
rules I doubt that be as close as this
do you notice where 0 begins see that
there's a mark there yeah babe right
there
of course but it doesn't start the
actual ruler doesn't start from 0 right
so if I were to say try and measure out
if I would try to measure out well how
far this actual projector screen is from
the wall okay if I were trying to do
that
okay so I would say well I'm gonna you
know Ram the end of the ruler against
the wall and then I'm gonna take a
measurement okay but of course there's
this little extra bit that isn't taking
into account okay so when I say start
era maybe you want to draw a little
diagram kind of like this
if your ruler as most rulers don't do I
think carpentry rule is a problem the
exception if your rule a doesn't start
at zero then a stop Eric and creep eight
if you don't pay careful attention to
that okay so where does the instrument
begin is what this something about that
don't worry that's what this error is
about now secondly and related right in
this case my ruler is intact but
frequently measuring instruments are not
going to be intact and it's going to be
damaged right so here's the UM diagram I
might draw if I have ruler and it's what
you have is your that's attached
directly to the drawing show me their
inner lock okay this is a different kind
of problem so I'll talk about that in a
second
here's the image on what uniform suppose
we have a robot and it's just kind of
like this one but snapped off and it's
kind of like yeah you know what
who's the person that you've got the
cannon 3 4 5 6 etcetera so if you have a
broken instrument and I'm talking about
say links at the moment if I were
measuring mass I have this really old
set of scales at home for like new city
kitchen and when there's nothing on it
it says 15 grams but that's kind of like
the equivalent of this it's broken to
start with so you kind of have to do
this compensations obviously if you
measure from there if I measure
something and it goes all the way up 2 3
4 5 it's not 5 centimeters long if I
begin to it's 33 ok so these are areas
about where do you begin
ready start measuring from a secondary
or category and this is getting at one
on the puget a scale errors okay so
firstly let's talk about well if you've
got with some giving this if you've got
an instrument and you know the markings
are gone or even if the markings aren't
on but if it's wrongly calibrated
so for instance when you're getting and
did you scale something like that you
might notice on the scale there's a
button that says zero right and it's
like I want nothing to be there and I
call that zero or maybe I have like a
beaker or something like that I placed
on on the scale and I want that to be
zero I don't want you to worry about the
mass of the beaker so if you do this
wrong if you calibrate incorrectly
perhaps you calibrate with one beaker
then you use another one it's slightly
different then you're going to introduce
an error in the scale because that's
what it weakens right or of course as
here's woman actually was either really
tolerated or no calibration right if
there's no scale that's a visible or
there's like you know it's been rubbed
off or something like that then that's
gonna cause you some problems
okay now the next one's a bit more
interesting and I'm going to use this to
help me so mmm no clock okay now what I
want you to notice is kind of by the
design of an analog clock well this one
has three hands yeah and because of the
way the hands work they can't all sit
like right on the surface of the clock
and it looks like the order is which
makes sense the hour hand is closest to
the actual surface then the minute hand
is above it and then the second hand is
the one that's first down okay now
what's interesting about this I'm gonna
have to do is a few different ways but
if you look at this sort of side on okay
rather than straight on if you're
looking at it side on okay you're
actually not measuring to the right spot
where the second hint is okay draw a
diagram here with me
we'll use a ruler for the sake of it
being simple if you've got this um 0 1 2
3 4 5 object again okay and suppose so
ruler on if you've got an object 0 1 2 3
and that's where you okay again if we
sort of simulate let's get another color
case looking at it from a different
angle you can kind of imagine what's
gonna happen let's put it I say over
here okay I didn't do very well as you
can tell now what's going to happen is
you put that line of sight from the
object sorry from the eye to the
do you see what's going to happen put a
dotted line like that just like with the
clock and you looking at the second hand
and you're not at the right angle you're
going to come across all the way at four
right or the same era could occur in the
other direction if you're looking from
this side okay so what we call it zero
no this is called stuck to that page
it's called parallax this is called
parallax which is a really cool way you
could name a DC Comics bad guy after
that parallax means or something and
because you're not straight on you're
not getting an accurate result and
actually honestly it's very hard to do
that all the time
okay one last category error and error
and it's kind of most important one for
us mathematically even though we want to
take all of them into account the last
one is what we call the limit of the
instrument about my meter rule up back
on the screen point I don't know why I
just put there okay now there are
actually two sides to this rule up you
can see that they have different scales
okay I just want you to focus on the top
one what are the units actually being
marked out there they're centimeters
yeah I know it's be hard to see because
I've zoomed in so far but each one of
these is is once in available okay so as
a result if I put an object against this
ruler and suppose it's I don't know say
that long okay so it's somewhere in
between these measurements okay
you kind of don't know is it you know is
it 2.3 2.4 is in 2.5 it's very hard to
tell with any accuracy because you have
no actual markings on your instrument so
when we say the limits of the instrument
we mean the ruler like this right the
closest it can measure is to the closest
area right even if I cannot know oh two
point one to point two I can definitely
say of a point like
it's going to be closer to one side
versus the other does that make sense
this is the idea of rounding isn't it so
I can say oh I'm going to round down for
sure because look at that distance it
must be closer this way even though who
look sure how much closer okay